hey screen junkies welcome to honest
trailer commentaries aka three guys
talking about it that's right the scary
clown movie we made an honest trailer
about it and now you're gonna find out
our behind-the-scenes thoughts if you
stick around to the end we have some cut
jokes which weren't good enough to make
it into the actual video come to this
welcome to this one though especially
Gilbert joined by Joestar hello by Dan
Morelle hello and we saw it we did we
liked it and the fans chose it for us -
honestly rip it to shreds to be fair we
we probably would have done this it was
very lucky that it came out during this
fan choice window because we would have
done it probably wouldn't we would have
done yeah but I'm glad that we're able
to put it up to a vote and just put that
extra bullet point like and the fans
wanted to bring it especially after dark
tower this really warmed my heart yes
Stephen King adaptations or either like
pretty good or they're over here yeah
and then like thinner is right in the
middle yeah I did enjoy this how much do
you think this could have even possibly
been cognizant of stranger things did
this have enough time to copy stranger
things because it felt like r-rated
stranger things plus a spooky clown I
don't think I mean it was being
developed before strangers right yeah I
mean it's been a development hell
forever
I brought skip from the mage from the
Maze Runner who we were just talking
about well Poulter was originally going
to be he's a good enough actor now all
his name will Poulter yeah that's good
was gonna be penny wise and then he left
and really yeah he was gonna be penny
wise so yeah this has been turning
around forever I don't I don't know I
think it's just general nostalgia I
think it's this the moment that we're in
right now I don't know how much it could
have yeah you're just ready to really
caught that wave of well stranger things
was copying it so this really didn't rip
off anything that stranger things hadn't
already taken from yeah this movie yeah
or book so yeah I mean but like so the
reason stranger things is good is
nostalgia is a big part of it but it's
only a part of it
cuz this also was a solid horror movie
it looked really good the director I
don't know what else he's done but he's
he's one to watch
ya know he's genuinely creepy yeah what
I loved about this is I hate jump scares
but I generally like horror movies
because if they're well done if they're
well crafted and I like that this movie
was genuinely just creepy
yeah just like just very well
constructed not you know just you know I
mean it had a few of the other things to
the regular horror movie has to have but
it's just well designed and constructed
they hit dairy really well
I mean Jerry's practically one of the
characters your character but even in
the old TV mini-series I feel like in
the in the beginning maybe it's just
because of like the 50 sheen of the of
the originals first half like aside from
his brother getting murdered like you
don't really get the feeling that dairy
is like this weird screwed-up cursed
place yeah every now and then someone
will tell you that but the movie doesn't
really like show you that that well I
thought this movie did a really good job
of dairy being like this kind of just
yeah movie they do a pretty good job how
I'm full of creeps yes everyone was like
completely oblivious to everything and
just didn't even know what was going on
and and yeah they didn't this did so
much better I think than the TV series
did which I watched the TV series
because well behind the scenes action we
were gonna do an honest trailer on it
and I went home and watched all three
hours of it and came into the office the
next day and everyone was like nope
swedgin else so in my mind work ahead of
time never do any more work than you
have to make it in time to halfway
through a first draft and I was like
this might be the best work I've done
here oh no wow so yeah the TV the TV
series first of all had the whole thing
to do a look and 2:19 three hours which
this movie is half of it mm-hm and I
maintain this is the more interesting
half yeah I will be very curious to see
what it was gonna be called it chapter
two isn't going to be because this is
the better I have I've read the book
I've seen it now this I think this is
the more interesting half of the story
so it'll be
I'll be very intrigued deceiver but
they've already departed as far as what
characters are important and sure a lot
of mythology so they have license to
kind of make it their own
I hope they do well I I'm interested
because you know we hid it in the
trailer a lot but like the sort of
nostalgia wave that it rides I'm curious
if chapter 2 can now sort of like see
what that nostalgia ride means for like
these are these adults right we've seen
our nostalgia through their lens you
know of the 80s and early 90s and now
you can kind of see like I don't know
like the Arrested Development they've
now gone through because of Pennywise
but I hope they just make the decision
to not flash forward that far ahead so
we're in like 2003 and everyone's in
Healy's and listening it's a prodigy I'm
completely fine with that I'm ready for
that wave minister I also want it to be
the exact same cast as the second half
of the original miniseries I wanted to
just an old old harry potter
myth unfortunately that a few i mean as
many of them as we can oh you mean the
original yeah the original original I
know we can't have Ritter but you know
yeah I want Harry Anderson and yeah get
them all back in Jenko jeans alright
let's watch the honest trailer for it we
asked you to vote for the 2017 movies
you wanted us to make it on its trailer
for now you're number three choice
floats to
[Music]
from the twisted mind of Stephen King
master of horror suspense and really
inconsistent movie adaptations that one
to keep their hands to themselves that
was so scary
it killed the actual clown industry life
in Derry Maine has its ups and clowns is
looking in the gutter and this piece of
it will eat you alive unless each of
speeds on people's fear is beautiful
fear or maybe eat you alive and feeds on
your fear I feed on your fear or maybe
you'll just scare you real bad and leave
you alone it's kind of muddled rule of
thumb main characters get spooked
everyone else's clown food plus now then
you had the book is there any insight
what's the deal does he eat fear does
eat people the book is very bizarre it's
very long it took me like five months to
listen to the audiobook typically live
much listen to the whole thing
he's very ancient hmm and he appeared a
meteor he did came into he crash-landed
on earth and there's a reference to the
turtle later on there's rituals involved
he's kind of just this force and yeah
it's a bit muddy as well he kind of is
he fear is what kind of attracts him
likes it's kind of his power but he also
has to feed on people and what I liked
about it was that and the the movie
doesn't really go into this and the book
where it does go into is he's more of
like this force for evil like he kind of
just feeds on evil because there's
there's this whole side things in the
book where every 27 years in Derry
there's been some huge calamity like a
factory explosion a bar burning down or
being set on on fire this this gang
being shot up and on Main Street excuse
me there's always this calamity and he
it'sit'sit's intimated that he exerts
his influence over people kind of like
what we see him do it with Henry Bowers
in this movie that he kind of causes
these huge evil things where a bunch of
people get killed and that like feeds
him so he kind of just feeds on like
negative energy and also people all
right so he's like a like a YouTube
prankster just a prank bro prank yes
great and much like YouTube pranksters
if you stop paying attention to them
they journey to the ideally child murder
capital of America and meet a losers
Club full of Goonies and Lost Boys kids
who'd beat One Direction fans in a
screaming contest extra nasty there's
the leader the sick one the bookworm the
kid from stranger things in glasses the
girl one and also the other two whose
character development got cut for time
Mikey doesn't say a word for 45 minutes
of screen time do you really want to
turn one of the books main characters
into the Winston of the movie really
okay movie you're the movie pawpaws the
original does not do much better like
the two in this one where we were like
the other two either they're the same in
the miniseries so he's just the Bar
Mitzvah boy who's afraid of flute woman
flute woman yes yeah the thing Mike
particularly though confused me because
his role in the book is as the historian
yeah he's the guy that is there and and
knows the history of the town they gave
that to the new kid so what's this new
kid in the book right that's the thing
is is that that's what kind of surprised
me a little bit is that Mike kind of had
a role and then they took that role away
from him and kind of gave it to Ben yeah
at watching it I really didn't see how
it was more useful for Ben to do it than
it would have been for Mike to do it
unless they've got some big things
planned for really changing things up in
the second one and maybe they do but
that was curious to me just watching
as a fan of the original was the idea of
kind of taking this business away from
Mike and he literally disappears for
like 45 minutes of the movie like he's
gone gone yeah
and giving it to Ben I add I'm anxious
to see how they pay that off because it
it struck me as a little odd that they
would take it would take that bit of
business and give it to another
character yeah I don't think I really
would have noticed anything but I
haven't read the book yeah so that is
his absence is pretty conspicuous if
he's the one that brings them all back
together or whatever
generally that's it that add the source
material yeah as Rick yeah is mike is
kind of the guy that's anchors back and
is kind of the one that calls them back
yeah in the miniseries it's a little
more glaring because the way they frame
the miniseries is you see everyone as
adults and then they keep flashing back
mm but he's the one sort of gathering
them letting him know yeah but then in
the flashbacks
he's just absent so more glaring in the
in the miniseries but yeah that's a
weird choice it's a strange choice we'll
see what they do in the second movie I
don't know yeah let's keep watching
really okay movie your the movie our new
favorite I will as each child's fear
preys on them in a unique form just try
not to know I can't pray see this exact
same way don't let go off on their own
the slow walk notice something else
[Music]
and slowly walk towards it so we
originally entered this in a grid and
ended up doing it yeah until a monster
pops out
[Music]
y'all know you can just say nope and
walk the other way right I mean that's a
classic horror movie yeah yeah dog paws
yeah that's the classic choice just
leave just leave in the movie ends
there'd be no movie but yeah I can't now
that you've said that I can't unsee
there's a definite pattern though what's
that I'm gonna walk towards it and even
get scarier and they're still like no
I'm gonna keep going yeah I think that's
a it's an odd though to how well put
together the movie is because that I've
been in I've been in horror movies where
that happens and I'm like what are you
doing but the way that they structured
this one I didn't even notice that they
were doing that until you know yeah a
whole yeah but it's also coded kind of
training your audience in a way sort of
for like a pavlov response it's like
once somewhere in your subconscious
you're like oh no they saw the weird
thing and they're still walking and that
yeah in the yeah yeah boring editor's
note here just kind of behind the scenes
on how we structure these things we
originally the first cut these those are
all in a grid so John said basically he
talked and then you just saw like eight
different pictures all at once which is
how we do sometimes it's it's the
question of is it funnier if we show
them all at once like baby Thor's flying
horse is a great Joe star idea to put
them all on one grid or is it more
effective to string them out and I think
we also the first cut and set it's more
effective if we string those out so that
you hit that point joke is a repetition
right Kevin of that Kevin TJ nailed that
too like yeah looks really well no yeah
it's fun heroes they are they really are
just the little things like Georgie
jumping back going ah when he says the
penny wise is in the sewer like these
little beats that we don't tell them to
put in there yep don't just put in there
they're great they good good job editors
you're not watching but good job good
job
keep practicing working on our next one
and good job you JT press play ride the
wave of nostalgia that still sweeping
Hollywood and get your required dose of
80's pop culture like new kids on the
block
bullets that terrible street fighter
give up street fighter one time you can
only be ready but boys are still years
off not knowing how aid works
depressing case of a nice nostalgic shag
and of course the kid from stranger
things which makes you nostalgic for
stranger things which makes you
nostalgic for the 80s which makes you
nostalgic for Stephen King's it and the
circle is complete feast on this
enjoyable movie adaptation of a popular
TV adaptation of a creepy book that
managed to out creep Tim Curry and
wisely punted the boring adult stuff
that no one remembers to the sequel
whereas made some radical departures
from the original book ditching the
fifties era that preteen gangbang scene
and the appearance of Maturin the god
turtle who teaches Billy how to perform
the magic ritual of chewed guys made
that one up the whole Stephen King's
really weird that's in there Wow
make sister cut it but at the same the
book we should talk about the book yet
having just recently finished it it's
weird yeah and Stephen King is a little
weird
beyond the turtle stuff and the tude and
but you have to bite their each other's
tongues and tell jokes and it's pretty
nuts but there is the there is the
tunnel scene yep where they all take
turns with Beverley which is just really
strange and even throughout the rest of
the book he is often very focused on the
the the happenings of different people's
genitalia what level of attention
they're giving certain situation it's
very strange it's odd it's it's a weird
thing to to return to again and again
I'm just going to say this a little
off-putting okay apparently there is a
draft of the script that includes it a
writer got pulled from it that I think
it's Carrie the truth yeah whoever that
is did the did a draft that he was like
I'm walking if we don't like do this
hard are disturbing version of it
and and he is no longer with the project
yeah that was a good decision yeah to
necessary that is a weird scene it's the
whole idea of it is that labor united in
their quest to kill penny wise but then
they can't get out they're lost and
Beverly it's like how are we going to
all become united behind something again
and she's like I know run train everyone
has to have sex with me and then that
eats it's weird it's there's no reason
for it to be in any of the animations
and really
cocaine's a hell of a drag yeah Stephen
King what the [ __ ] bomb but that is just
weird
even the Oh chewed turtle enormous girth
all that stuff makes me even sadder that
dark tower was just awful because like
the second half of the Dark Tower series
is king at his most off the rails so
like all that weird stuff and is like
standalone books where you're like why
is there a turtle God in your clown book
all that stuff just starts to just
collapse in on this Jenga tower of
Stephen King weirdness and I would have
loved to have seen all of that on the
big screen that sounds good so how many
boring books do I have to get through
before that part four good ones and
they're not boring they're good and then
he just I won't even call the second
half bad to not anger Dark Tower fans
but I will say that they're like
ridiculous school no all right I'm into
it
speaking of it let's keep going so enjoy
a horrifying trip down memory lane that
submits clouds as a scariest childhood
thing since dolls and puppets making
boatloads of cash for everyone involved
and guarantees that somebody somewhere
just greenlit a Maximum Overdrive rebate
yeah
I don't know if I'm ready for another
Stephen King Assange you guys it's gonna
be a bumpy ride
like a blood drive
dorky Pig way more important in Chapter
two
mr. Broflovski why write a joke when
your real name is Finn wolf our Teen
Wolf on G chug young Sheldon just as for
Bev
but doctor I am Pagliacci just been
attacked by some insane clown posse
Stephen King's
scats batman came out on june 23rd in
lethal weapon 2 came out on July 7th so
dare either gets movies really early
school gets out really late or they
wanted to give us one more hit that
sweet sweet nostalgia people actually
people ask what's it like to write
honest trailers the answer is you're
watching it and things like that pop
into your head yeah you're watching the
movie admittedly the I think second time
and you see that as Mark easy to go like
I'm looking up those rules I didn't
notice the first time dead and I was
your catch and yeah this when the movies
good you have to resort to that yeah
yeah I mean I get if I get Batman but
really the like you're already pushing
it with Batman and you're like lethal
weapon to also it's like it's come on we
don't need did lethal weapon - was that
the reference that made or break the
movie right they were all how hard is it
to just do Batman or to pick a weapon -
solid solid but we just are trying to
maintain the time-space continuum yeah I
know that's exactly it's a little bit of
excessive nostalgia I believe they they
they they oh end they over nostalgic
over nostalgia I did look up however the
Nightmare on Elm Street 5 release date
did line up with where the story was at
that point so that's a good job there
all right script supervisor whoever does
that I'm sure somebody did a hand waiver
just like whatever no one will notice
Dan noticed and now the world alright
let's see some deleted scenes get ready
for a film that blends horror comedy and
nostalgia and a tidy little package that
sold way more tickets than anyone
expected because the marketing was
scarier than the movie itself
[Music]
pause yes so this was just it doesn't
play too well because that's like a VR
experience and just like rhythmically it
kind of takes too long by man the
marketing campaign was good for this man
yes at Comic Con when they had those
lowly old people or holding the balloon
I was gonna bring them up because um at
first like you were like oh man they're
creepy but then at night when 400,000
people were trying to all use the same
like path to get back to their hotel
rooms they're all tired and mad and
there's this like it like raincoats it's
like coming up to a horse and you're
just like I hate you okay III didn't
have a traffic jam situation I just see
them like kind of by themselves just
like just a corner I they would stand
there alone like that I don't have you
ever been to comic-con so there's the
skybridge yeah crosses yes a major thing
if you're under the Convention Center
and they would just stand there even if
it wasn't crowded with these balloons
for hours and they never looked up they
never saw their face they didn't react
they're like royal guards or whatever
with the hats yeah it's good good
marketing good job great what wear
yellow marketed real nailed it really
nailed that one to that big house that
you saw there was down the street from
my old apartment oh so he walked by the
house every day
ooh it's one of those things it was like
great marketing but like they announced
it and it was sold out within three
hours so it's literally like six weeks
of having walking past a Disneyland that
you can't go in because watch all of the
puberty happen when Beverly joins the
gay
she's got no fear a badass haircut and
fights a monster way more frightening
than Bill skarsgård in a lace frog are
you still my girl me personally I'd
rather live with Pennywise the dashing
president then I would March the
molesting dad
that's part of a in the book that's that
part of the story is part of Pennywise
exerting his basically what he does in
the lighter part of the book with the
kids as heroes is that he can't get them
so he starts influencing the people and
the adults in their lives to like try to
kill them for him
which is even scarier I think that the
clown be like in the book that's
Beverly's dad is somebody who he kind of
take that cuz they kind of describes
like a fog comes over them and they he
starts going after well we'll see if
that holds up in court well see it
wasn't me it was evil clown exerting his
influence on me if only your honor this
man clearly knows the ritual of choose
I'm just a caveman
I hear man's been taken over by a clown
and on television that confuses me but I
do know one thing
the Richer will shoot alright let's keep
watching
@e @e @e h @ aj that's not even big boy
but you've never been not a girl not yet
a woman spirits reference al Rudnick
penny wise reparation can't sleep
clothes reference penny wise dances to
anything mean killer clown from outer
space true it's for a meteor yes yeah
that's it okay yeah that's it that's it
that's it guys that's it hey what more
is there to say we'll be back for
chapter 2 that's for sure landing on it
see ya well go see it yeah and yeah I
don't know is are there other Stephen
King projects you'd like to see them
take another crack at
[Music]
no nope I'm good I like the old crappy
Stephen King movies yeah they're they're
fine just the way they are just make
them 4k release them in a giant box set
and I will watch it feel okay cool I
still think there's a great book
accurate version of The Shining to be
told
okay but is it worth the effort probably
probably not because it won't be Kubrick
so it won't be as good and people will
be like why did we do this yeah exactly
anyways that's it for us today tune in
next week when we cover your next
selection mm-hmm which how can I tease
this what's a good way to tease this I'm
just waiting I'm not doing a bit I'm
asking oh is this the one with the
inventor nope now the other one now this
is let's see oh is the other one where
are we gonna stay in this video until
you figure out what the next movie is
now we're gonna grab it okay let's not
stay in this any long we're gonna get
out we're gonna you're right we should
get out we should get out now and we'll
see you next week perfect
[Laughter]
[Music]
you